بمعنى التدخل في الانتخابات
، كانت المكالمة هي التي حركت الأحداث ،
لذلك يجب أن يكون لدينا هنا
رئيس بلدية أمريكا
آه رئيس البلدية جولياني ولدينا
أندريه يارماش دفع أوكرانيا المترددة
في السياسة الأمريكية المنقسمة
التي نعرفها بالفعل من
خلال النصوص والشهادة التي
تم الضغط عليها من جولياني  ليعلنوا عن
التحقيقات
المهمة للرئيس ترامب آنذاك ، لكن
هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي سمعنا فيها صوته الفعلي ، وأريد
كثيرًا أن أرى أن بلدينا
قادران على العمل معًا
جولياني تملق المستشار الرئاسي الأوكراني
على الطرف الآخر من الخط.  في البداية
روجت لنظريات المؤامرة
التي تم فضحها بأن أوكرانيا وليست روسيا كانت متورطة في
تدخلنا في الانتخابات في عام 2016 وحاولت
إيذاء
حملة ترامب في نوفمبر الماضي ،
تلقيت معلومات من محقق دولي موثوق
بأن هناك قدرًا معينًا من
النشاط
في أوكرانيا خلال  انتخابات عام 2016
التي شارك فيها
مسؤولون أوكرانيون وأوكرانيون  معظمهم من المسؤولين الذين تسألهم
سفارتنا وربما مسؤولون أمريكيون آخرون ،
أعني أن البيان كان
لإثارة الأوساخ على أه
آنذاك المرشح ترامب وبول مانافورت
بحلول وقت المكالمة في يوليو 2019 ، كان جو
بايدن قد ظهر بالفعل
كواجهة للحزب الديمقراطي  عداء
لتحدي
الرئيس ترامب وهو يبحث عن الأوساخ عن بايدن
مثل المزاعم التي لا أساس لها من
التعاملات الفاسدة في أوكرانيا عندما كان
نائب
الرئيس أصبحت أولوية بالنسبة لترامب
ومستشاره منذ فترة طويلة
طوال المكالمة التي استمرت حوالي 40 دقيقة
ضغط جولياني مرارًا وتكرارًا على
القيادة الأوكرانية
الإعلان علنًا عن التحقيقات في
هذا الأمر أيضًا ،
وهو أمر كان سيفيد بلا شك
حملة إعادة انتخاب
ترامب والمرشح المتضرر بايدن ، استمع إلى
كيف يحدد جولياني ما هو مطلوب
وما نحتاجه كل ما نحتاجه
للرئيس هو أن
يقول إنني سأقوم بصراحة  المدعي العام
المسؤول سيحقق
ويبحث عن
الأدلة الموجودة حاليًا وأنا  هناك
أي دليل آخر على
التورط في انتخابات عام 2016 ومن
ثم يجب أن ينفد الأمر.
كمحام
، يبدو أنه يبدو وكأنه عروس ، يجب على شخص ما في
أوكرانيا أن يأخذ الأمر على محمل الجد
في المكتب الرئاسي الأوكراني ،
لقد أخذوا الأمر على محمل الجد
حينها حيث كانت البلاد الآن تخوض
حربًا يائسة
ضد المتمردين المدعومين من روسيا في
شرقها وتعتمد بشدة علينا  الأسلحة
والمساعدات العسكرية للصمود
بما في ذلك ملايين الدولارات التي
تم تجميدها من قبل الإدارة الرابحة
بينما تابع جولياني هذه
التحقيقات السياسية مع
مراعاة الحاجة إلى علاقة قوية
مع واشنطن
، حاول مستشار الرئيس الأوكراني
في المكالمة طمأنة
جولياني في التحقيقات التي أجراها
نرغب في النظر
ونحن جاهزون
هذا اليوم
اتصلنا فورًا بالتنسيق أه
للعمل أه والتحقيق في
كل شيء  لقد قمت بإدراجها في القائمة ولكن
يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون بشكل خاص إنهم قلقون من الانغماس
في السياسة الأمريكية
خاصة عندما اقترح جولياني مرارًا وتكرارًا
أن الامتثال
سيفتح الباب لتوثيق
العلاقات الأوكرانية بيننا
حتى أن الاجتماع الرئاسي يقوض
تأكيدات الرئيس الأمريكي السابق
بأنه لم يسع أبدًا للحصول على مزايا سياسية
من أوكرانيا  لتأمين
دعمنا لما يسمى quid pro quo ، لا أريد
شيئًا ،
لا أريد شيئًا ، لا أريد مقايضة
الآن يمكننا أن نسمع جولياني
يعرض عرضه إذا كان بإمكانه الإدلاء ببعض التصريحات
في الوقت المناسب بأنه يدعم
نظام إنفاذ قانون نزيه وعادل و
أن تذهب هذه التحقيقات
إلى أي مكان يجب أن يذهبوا إليه ليتم إدارتها من قبل
أشخاص صادقين من
شأنه أن ينقي الأجواء
جيدًا وأعتقد أنه
سيمكنني من المجيء وإتاحة
الفرصة لي لأتحدث إلى الرئيس وأرى ماذا
يمكنني أن أفعل للتأكد
من وضع أي سوء تفاهم جانبًا
وربما
أعتقد نوعًا ما أن هذا هو هذا
يمكن  يكون شيئًا جيدًا
لوجود علاقة أفضل بكثير
حيث نفهم بعضنا البعض حقًا
وفقًا لمعرفي الواقعي ، فقد اقتربوا من
العديد من المسؤولين الأوكرانيين السابقين
الذي كان يستمع إلى المكالمة ،
وفهم جيدًا أنه تحدث إلى CNN
الشهر الماضي عن غضبه لأنه  سمع أن
جولياني حاول إبرام
صفقة هددت بكلماته
الأمن القومي لأوكرانيا ،
دعني أذكرك بأننا دولة
تخوض حربًا مع روسيا
لسنوات عديدة ، لذا فإن أي شيء
يتعلق بمبادلة أنت تعرف أنه
يخدم أه في علاقتنا الثنائية
في مقابل
محاولة إشراكنا في سياساتنا الداخلية ،
هذا
خطأ على العديد من المستويات
الأخلاقية وربما حتى من الناحية القانونية من
خلال نهاية المكالمة ، بدا أن الجانب الأوكراني
يفهم
بالضبط ما
كان من المتوقع أن يفعله الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي
لإبقاء واشنطن في صف واحد.  لقد وافقوا
على المكالمة على الأقل
، أنا متأكد من أن زيلينسكي
سيقول ذلك
نعم ، نعم أيها الفتى الثاني
الذي سيصدقني  أندري
أن
هذا سيكون مفيدًا لنا
جميعًا ، وقد نفى جولياني ارتكاب أي مخالفات في
أوكرانيا
، وقال إنه كان يحاول فقط مساعدة
موكله الشخصي على
التفوق ، بالطبع كانت هذه وغيرها من
المحاولات العدوانية لإقناع أوكرانيا
ونفى بشدة من قبل مسؤولي الإدارة في
ذلك الوقت.  في أول محاكمة للرئيس السابق ترامب
والتي تمت
تبرئته في النهاية من قبل مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي
، من الصعب معرفة ما إذا كان سماع
جولياني
يضغط بلا هوادة على أوكرانيا بهذا الشكل
إذا كان بإمكانه أن يقول شيئًا كهذا
للحصول على محادثته الخاصة ، فستقطع
شوطًا طويلاً  طريق طويل مع
الرئيس
لحل المشاكل من شأنه أن يؤثر بأي شكل من الأشكال
على نتيجة التصويت على الإقالة